Speaker 1: All right, it is great to be back
and to be ready to hear from the audience and
hear what is on your mind, we are rapidly
approaching one billion views on YouTube,
which is just incredible. We'll be doing
something very special for that. But more
on that later. Let's go to the phones.
They're not really phones anymore.
We will go to Dischord David Pakman dotcom slash.
Dischord is the place where you can talk to me.
And I'm so eager to hear from folks. Let's start
today. I don't even know where we want to start.
How about Kevin from Denver? You were on the air.
Speaker 2: David, how are you doing? I hope
you had a real good vacation.
Speaker 1: I did. Thank you.
Speaker 2: So I was looking at your interview
with Phil Gursky, and it's kind of interesting,
the bedfellows that have been made with tweets
from people like Lauren Bobert or Nick Fuentes,
who all of a sudden agree with a lot of
the sentiments of the Taliban. Yeah, and
yeah, very strange bedfellows there. But I was
actually curious to kind of go back a little
bit further towards the Iran nuclear deal. And
I grew up in a house with a lot of Islamophobia.
And the only thing I can really think of is so
we go into the war on terror. We go into Iraq for
weapons of mass destruction. And now all of this,
you know, we've gotten out of there and country
surrounding countries like Afghanistan now taken
back over by the Taliban. So I was curious, with
the Iran nuclear deal, the only kind of rhetoric
I heard from the right wing was we got into a bad
deal and especially Donald Trump. So was there any
legitimate criticisms with the Iran nuclear deal?
Basically from the right I mean, even from
a left perspective, or was it mostly rooted
in this? We don't want countries in the Middle
East having any kind of nuclear capabilities.
Speaker 1: So I'm not sure. So you're saying
was there any valid criticism from the right
or the left? I mean, listen, let me tell you,
here's my thought on the Iran nuclear deal.
Go ahead. I don't think, given the circumstances
at the time that Barack Obama negotiated it,
that you were going to get anything much more
strict and where the right side was in saying
that Iran was regularly violating the deal. Iran,
as far as we know, stuck to the terms of the deal.
They allowed inspectors to go in and
look now, if you want to make the claim
they had secret facilities. So they were
showing inspectors, the official facilities,
but not they had all these other that stuff
is sort of unfalsifiable. If you want to
present some evidence that that was going
on, go ahead and do it. But the truth is,
they were abiding by the deal. It's the U.S.
that looks terrible when without anybody having
violated a deal, we just bail on it. And so
the criticisms from the right evaluating them,
listen, if they have evidence of something, then
they should bring it forward. At this point,
it seems like they've moved long, long moved on
from that. But no, I think it was a reasonably it
was a reasonable deal given what was possible at
the time. And to the best of our knowledge, Iran
was abiding by it until Trump bailed on the deal.
Speaker 2: Great answer. Just one last real quick
question. What do you think of anyone
watching the show a little bit this past
week and seeing the guests views on it? But
what do you think of Biden standing behind
the decision to to pull the troops out?
Speaker 1: I am supportive of it. We have
like a 15 minute video with my full opinion
coming out on that soon. So I won't, like,
redo that segment. But I am generally supportive
and I look forward to hearing your thoughts on
the full video when it's out.
Speaker 2: Yeah, great. Yeah.
Thanks for having me today.
Speaker 1: All right. Thanks,
Kevin from Denver. They're very important
topics. Prescient, I would even say.